ça lui est ce que vous vous souvenez de
ma vidéo du million sorti en janvier le
premier et sky vidéo dont il fallait
sortir en moins de 10 minutes si vous
l'avez pas vu ou si vous l'avez pas fait
je vous mets un lien au dessus de moi et
dans la description et si vous l'avez
fait mais que vous n'avez pas réussi à
en sortir
non ce n'était pas une boucle vous avez
un plan de la vidéo dans la description
de la vidéo du million ça me semble
clair
aujourd'hui nous allons faire un test
sur le mentaliste mais le mensonge mais
pour la première fois sur youtube vous
n'aurez pas à noter les points
regardez les vidéos normalement et à la
fin je serai précisément où vous en êtes
et où vous aviez bon ou pas alors si les
liens n'apparaissent pas à la fin de la
vidéo c'est à dire sur l'écran voulais
retrouver toujours en descriptions
n'hésitez pas si le concept vous plaît à
mettre 1 pouces bleus maintenant
précisément sur cette vidéo puisque
comme les autres vidéos elles sont en
ont répertorié ça servira à rien en fait
je vous souhaite une bonne vidéo et
bienvenue dans le premier test
interactif du youtube game cliquez sur
ce visage pas le mien l'autre